bonjour christine turc et de beauregard
bonjour nico large alors nous voilà
devant le bâtiment native dernière
construction emblématique de saint
quentin en yvelines qui vient d'être
livré par le groupe codic alors quelles
sont les caractéristiques de ce projet
alors déjà les caractéristiques de ce
projet c'est que c'est un projet qui est
réalisé par le promoteur codic promoteur
historique qui réalise beaucoup
d'opérations sur le territoire de saint
quentin est là qui vient de livrer
vraiment dans le quartier prime de 51 en
yvelines le dernier immeuble qui fait
dix neuf mille mètres carrés qui est en
herbe qui suit avec des plateaux de 2000
m² et surtout on ne le voit pas d'ici
mais il ya énormément de terrasses
végétalisées et un roof top avec une
terrasse de 500 m² donc ouverte aux
salariés et avec le dernier étage qui
sera disponible pour des salles de
réunion des événements etc et surtout la
particularité de cet immeuble c'est
qu'il est extrêmement vie très très
lumineux et au niveau de l'agencement
avec des matériaux de qualité des
matériaux très sobre et du coup au
niveau de l'aménagement ça sera vraiment
très facile à faire et bien évidemment
il a tous les labels développement
durable qui vont bien breeam excellente
et c est la particularité c'est que cet
immeuble donc à la base c'était
l'immeuble qui était occupé par la poste
qui faisait fi 1500 mètres carrés qui a
été racheté par codic au groupe alliance
en 2017 qui a démoli cet immeuble pour
reconstruire donc cet immeuble
emblématique et surtout la particularité
c'est qu'il a été loué à 83% par le
groupe orange qui va regrouper sur cet
immeuble quatre entités qui sont
répartis sur le territoire particularité
aussi c'est qu'il ya des commerces et
puis finalement ce projet c'est le début
aussi d'une reconfiguration de tout le
quartier de la gare avec le
développement de commerce voilà tout à
fait alors sur cet immeuble vous aurez
500 m² de commerces en rez-de-chaussée
mais il y a également tous les espaces
publics de l'hyper centre donc qu'ils
vont être réhabilités par saint quentin
en yvelines et donc tout ce quartier va
être complètement transformé avec bien
évidemment la continuité par codic du
projet à nos rouge donc démolition de
cette de cet immeuble qui donne vraiment
une très mauvaise impression lorsqu'on
arrive sur saint quentin en yvelines par
les transports en commun qui va être
démoli et codic va reconstruire trois
immeubles pour une surface totale de 2
20 mille mètres carrés avec des
rez-de-chaussée en pied d'immeuble avec
de la restauration des bars pour
vraiment animé tout ce quartier et à
voir surtout une transparence à partir
du maïdo sol jusqu'à la gare qui est
plutôt une gare plutôt confidentielle à
l'heure actuelle et qui sera vraiment
ouverte on va faire un bilan maintenant
de l'année 2020 en termes d'immobilier
d'entreprise une bonne année je crois
savoir que 2021 ça a été une bonne année
effet de rattrapage ou par rapport aux
colis d'où est ce que c'est une
véritable dynamique non alors fait une
véritable dynamique c'est vraiment une
très très bonne année par rapport déjà à
2020 mais bon ça c'était la période kovy
de confinement et cetera mais c'est une
bien meilleure année également que 2019
et une très bonne année par rapport aux
cinq dernières années la particularité
donc c'est con à 178 mètres carrés à la
fois à la location à l'acquisition
interpierre purement locaux d'activité
entrepôts avec la particularité de cette
année vraiment on est à peu près
équivalent en mètres carrés transactés
et en nombre de transactions donc on a
par exemple une des plus grandes
transactions ces ora nos qui s'est
transférée dans les locaux du futur à 2
sur 8 mille mètres carrés on a le cnas
qui a déménagé du parc ariane pour
s'installer et il a acquis en fait le
l'immeuble energia est en fait ce qu'il
ya d'intéressant sur 50 ans et que on
permet aux entreprises de déménager dans
des locaux aux dernières normes
environnementales qui répondent vraiment
aux demandes de des salariés aux
nouvelles modes d'organisation du
travail au télétravail bien évidemment
puisque on réduit les surfaces mais il
faut faire revenir les gens au bureau et
donc grâce à toutes ces opérations comme
celle de codic mais pas que on a
également cfc développement qui est en
cours de livrer le proxima 6 sur le pas
du lac on a également un tout petit peu
plus loin sur l'avenue
la venue du centre on a tout le quartier
des cadrans qui a été refait par baissé
et on a le bâtiment le follow qui doit
être livrée qui fait 6000 mètres carrés
une dernière question quels sont les
projets futurs sur n'ont pas cette année
puisque vous avez parlé de native et
aussi de faux lomé sur les prochaines
années 2023 2024 et peut-être 2025 même
tout à fait alors justement on a on a
établi un l'année dernière un schéma
directeur d'implantation économique ou
non nous avons repris l'ensemble des
zones d'activités de saint quentin donc
environ une trentaine qu'on a qualifié
et surtout on les a identifiés
classifiés et grâce à cela nous pouvons
travailler justement sur des nouveaux
projets avec des opérateurs
donc on a la zone du pas du lac qui est
en pleine reconversion également avec un
projet de parc d'activités r&d mais on a
également tout le pôle ski high-tech qui
est une nouvelle entrée sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin et de
paris saclay justement pour préciser ce
qu'est ce qu'ils aillent tex et plaisir
les clayes-sous-bois et la sortie d'el
encore en direction de plaisir tout à
fait alors là c'est un c'est un projet
très innovant puisque nous avons
regroupé quatre maires et nous avons
travaillé sur cinq zones d'activités
donc les deux zones d'activités de
plaisir sainte apolline gâtine la clé
saint-pierre à elancourt pis alloue à
trappes et puis alloue aux
clayes-sous-bois et donc on a fait tout
un travail d'étude mais très complet
aussi bien en développement économique
quand aménagements qu'en développement
durable etc donc on a fini ce travail
d'étude maintenant on commence à
travailler de façon opérationnelle et on
travaille sur plusieurs projets donc
avec spirit avec pau drid avec sa ré as
avec six gros et dont toute cette zone
va être complètement transformé on va
amener également de la mobilité les
aménagements vont être également refait
par rapport aux desserts à
l'accessibilité donc c'est vraiment un
grand projet d'envergure et c'est
surtout la future zone
industrielle point zéro qui
s'ouvre sur le plateau de saclay qui
serait une nouvelle entrée sur la région
ile de france eh bien merci christine
turc et de beauregard merci beaucoup
nicolas je rappelle que vous êtes la
directrice attractivité et immobilier
d'entreprise pour saint quentin en
yvelines